In a successful Kickstarter campaign to fund her cookbook,...
...Cambodian-famed chef Rotanak Ros, commonly known as Chef Nak, says...
...her country's culinary art is at risk of disappearing.
When I tried to find out how was Cambodian cuisine like 50 or 100 years ago,...
...I searched in libraries, talked to historians, archaeologists,...
...I couldn't find anything in particular.
The few written records of Cambodian culinary traditions...
...were almost completely erased in the mid-1970s by the Khmer Rouge regime.
During a four-year rule, 1.7 million people were killed...
...and Cambodian cuisine was reduced to a daily diet of watery rice porridge.
A daughter of Khmer Rouge survivors,...
...Ros says her mission is to make sure the world and her sons know about Khmer food.
The 200-page cookbook entitled "Nhum" or "Eat,"...
...consists of recipes for the country's signature dishes like kako soup,...
...banana rice cake, fried fish bread and stone crab stir-fry with pineapple.
While developing precise cooking measurements and nutritional information for her cookbook,...
...Ros also runs a home restaurant, offers food consultancy and hosts cooking shows.
I'm Chetra Chap for VOA News, Washington.